so I hate to start the show with
something so depressing and negative
today but I do want to tell you about
something unfortunate that's gone on
over the last couple of days we've been
covering polling in the 2020 Democratic
primary basically since the beginning of
2019 once the primary got going in
earnest with multiple candidates and
particularly as more serious candidates
got involved we've been following what
the polling has said and there's this
really horrible trend of when people in
my audience don't like the poll results
they unsubscribe from my youtube channel
and I know that it is sort of hard to
believe but as an example on Wednesday I
did a story about there are more and
more polls in which Elizabeth Warren is
solidly in second place over Bernie
Sanders there are still polls in which
Bernie's in second place but there are
more and more polls in which Bernie's in
second place and often building a lead
over Bernie Sanders now I gave the
disclaimer that a lot of people found
emailed me and said David that
disclaimer was unnecessary stupid and
obvious where I said I didn't do the
polls I'm not placing a value judgment
on whether these are good or bad results
for any particular contingent of the
Democratic primary electorate I'm merely
reporting to you what the polls say and
a lot of people had David why are you
even saying that like of course you're
just the messenger here and yet the clip
from Wednesday in which I said Elizabeth
Warren has mathematically provable
momentum and is beating Bernie in some
polls not my opinion it's what the polls
say was the clip that led to the highest
number of YouTube unsubscription x' this
week including people emailing me saying
that they are furious with me for the
coverage now no emails actually saying
what was wrong with the commentary the
few people who emailed me seemed to say
I'm ignoring that the polls are slanted
against Bernie and towards Warren well
tell me how if you're gonna make that
case tell me specifically how some polls
have her ahead others have Bernie ahead
the momentum over the last six months is
clearly with Elizabeth Warren this is
not my opinion it's just what the data
says we have even more polls now since I
did that story two days ago half
polls roughly have Bernie ahead half of
the polls roughly have Elizabeth Warren
ahead in second place remember Biden's
still in first place in all of these
polls looking now at the five polls that
have been published after the third
debate a week ago Bernie is in second
place in two of them Elizabeth Warren is
in second place in three of them if you
look at the sampling in the three of
them and in all five polls rather it's
reasonable if you look at the
methodology in all five polls it's
reasonable so I'm genuinely curious what
do we get like as a I'm asking you the
people who unsubscribed who by the way
even though they unsubscribe they still
appear in my comments every day what is
it that you're getting by unsubscribing
from me because I reported on the polls
I mean let I can handle it right I'm a
big boy the YouTube channel is still
gaining subscribers each day even when
people unsubscribed as a result of that
story the number of people who subscribe
was higher in the channel keeps growing
but it's more of a curiosity like what
message are you trying to send that I
shouldn't report on the polls or that I
should lie about the content of the
polls or like what is it that you want
me to do what message are you trying to
communicate to me by saying if you tell
us that a poll says Bernie's in third
place rather than second place we are
going to unsubscribe from your show if
you're a Bernie person I'm thinking out
loud here if you're a Bernie person and
you hear a poll has Bernie in third
place if you believe the poll you would
think it might inspire you to go out and
be an activist for Bernie if that's who
you're supporting if you hear me talk
about the poll results and you simply
don't believe them you think Bernie's
support is understated
you should still be happy because then
it will only lead to Bernie Sanders
over-performing and that would also be a
good thing for you like why be mad at me
if the polls are wrong and Bernie's
going to crush it then Bernie's going to
crush and then you can say I told you so
I just want to understand the logic of
unsubscribing over me reporting polls
and this act unfortunately the other I
don't even know if I want to wade into
this but the other area in which we saw
some of this was any time I would talk
about Tulsi Gabbard when she was still
doing well enough to participate in the
debate
was if I didn't talk about her I would
get angry Tulsi supporters saying their
unsubscribing because I'm not giving her
attention if I talk about her but in
anything other than the most glowing
terms that's also a problem worthy of
unsubscription and I just don't get like
water I just don't get what we're doing
and I know that people will notice the
sort of frustration in my voice here I
just don't get what it is that we are
doing by saying if you don't talk about
Tulsi I'm unsubscribing if you talk
about her but say anything other than a
completely gushing commentary I'm
unsubscribing if you mentioned that
polls you didn't do have Bernie Sanders
in third place I'm unsubscribing it's
dangerously close to the cancel culture
stuff that I think only exists among a
sliver of the left but does exist and I
think is extraordinarily problematic so
I want to hear from you explain to me
the logic of the entire thing we've got
a great bonus show for you today I hope
you'll become a member or a patron at
join pakman.com or patreon.com slash
david pakman show let me know your
thoughts on this polling unsubscribe
cancel culture stuff via Twitter I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and then
just as importantly the David Pakman
show is now on twitch at twitch.tv slash
David Pakman if you have an Amazon Prime
account you can subscribe on Twitch with
something called twitch prime for free
it costs you nothing every month because
you have Amazon Prime Amazon gives you a
free credit towards a twitch
subscription which you can then use to
sign up for the David Pakman show on
twitch we get paid you pay nothing
that's at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
and I hope you'll join me there for
upcoming streams during which I
sometimes take political quizzes I
sometimes open up the phone lines we do
a lot of different things on Twitch so
follow me there we've got a fantastic
program planned for you today I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / hackman blinka is a really unique
service for your phone tablet and web
browser and it is incredibly useful for
people like me
who love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blink Asst our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli nki st.com forward slash PA que ma n